hey Mario yeah this this patch of really
listen to this this really you've got to
be know about this it's okay what marry
others well he's got an email what's
this
what's his trilogy thing you just got
it's convenient all open I'm meeting
with Patrick it's fine I was I spent
their last couple days at his house we
had dinner last night I'm it's okay you
won't mind
this is Jonathan Mason we are gonna be
having our valued tainment today but
actually had a conversation with Patrick
last night and he asked me to host it so
we're going to call it entertainment
today because my background is
entertainment we're gonna have some fun
and today's topic is gonna be about 17
points of impersonating a leader and
I'll tell you when it comes hey Patrick
John we were talking I gotta say you're
gonna do the episode say yes you got to
be kidding me what are you doing on the
computer no I was just testing are you
how many times have I told you no one
gets in my desk
well what'd you have in mind well we
have an idea about doing 17 points of
impersonating a leader impersonating a
leader yeah it's kind of funny actually
who wants to impersonate leaders I mean
that's the biggest form of flattery unit
impersonating the leaf absolutely and
you think people would watch this video
absolutely I've married they'll all go
watch it you think people would actually
want to watch that I think so what if
they don't watch it now watch it
are you committed I'm absolutely in this
so here's what we're gonna do if they
don't watch it I want you you to dance
Armenians music my hope all oh my
scepter you can do the lightbulb music
can you dance to it there's no views I
can like move anything that's dance to
that I can if you guys are committed
more you to both you guys are being held
accountable people know you they know
they know you want okay so here's what
we do we make this one time because
there needs to be entertainment to it so
we can go live with it this time just
this one occasion and then depending on
the results
maybe we'll have other things they can
put cannot believe this is about three
thousand things of leadership three
thousand points of leadership that I
think will separate people from this is
the key here I think this is the most
important part of leadership that
separates the ordinary from the
extraordinary point number one is
accountability you have to be
accountable for your actions
and more importantly you have to hold
your people accountable for their
actions you can't just do things walk
away and expect somebody else to clean
up after you you can't have it that way
cannot play the victim so that's point
number one point number six so like I
was saying I want to talk to you about
leadership I don't want to talk to you
about point number six because point
number six is a little bit more
important than number five and not as
important as number seven did you get it
did you get it okay so number number six
is probably my favorite because has to
with clutter you have to unclutter your
life and the
more you can unclutter means the more
you can focus the more you can focus the
more you can improve and when you're
improving you have nothing to worry
about
when you improve you have nothing to
worry about nothing to worry about
did you get it okay because there was a
buddy of mine from the Army I remember
he called me I couldn't found me on
Facebook he called me he said he was
hungry I said let's do lunch we sat down
we ate we chewed we swallowed food was
good we were still hungry order dessert
I had some more dessert he was still
thirsty what does the more want or more
academic Attica
Hannah if I never had a ticket eat
okay Jenn yes okay so point number 10
like I was saying is clutter you have to
keep on cluttering your life because the
more basically the more clutter that is
out of your life the better off you're
gonna be
so let's keep going because I want to
talk to you guys about a point number 15
which is better than point number 14 136
36 has to do with maxing out think about
this what was the last time you maxed
out I don't care what you're black white
green Hispanic Asian Jewish Christian
whatever it is when was the last time
that you actually maxed out see I
remember one time one of my chips
because I mean I've been to Florence
Italy Tuscany how do you score now you
get for NASCAR races Kentucky Derby Palm
Springs Palm Desert George police Hall
are they up it was a great time yeah all
over the place okay all okay see you
have to max out what we're having here
people that are trying to match south
but here they have anybody in your big
shop that just doesn't want to go with
the extra mile see here's one thing I
realize about point number 37 point
number 37 which is right after 36 has to
do with getting people out of their
comfort zone right
what happens is you have to get people
uncomfortable don't be afraid to
challenge of people because when it goes
to the levels here you have to
collaborate if they're not gonna
collaborate you have to know when to
shove them in you have to know want to
go all in that's the only way gonna get
those results silly video but today's
message is whatever you do try to have
some fun at your workplace even if you
have to get a couple other guys to have
some humor with it get him to get it put
something fun to get out your work
environment meanwhile that's my message
to do week two however we're not done
because I want you to watch these two
silly guys who made this whole thing
happen today show you how to properly
dance to Armenian music what now that
she's I told you I told you now you got
to show the dance moves and you let him
influence you you need to be tougher
than that
there you go show us the dance dance
moves
ready interchange it's about to come up
I wanna see some weapons there you go
there you go cut that show
very product into training